wasn't really in a hurry to do another
podcast after I did like 10 Minute
Podcast years ago and then I was like
stop doing podcasts for a couple years
was like I don't care I I wasn't
necessarily like unless it was the right
thing I I don't you know I wanted to do
a podcast that I knew I was going to
enjoy yeah you were you were out of the
podcast for a while huh yeah yeah I
finished up doing podcasts the doing the
10 Minute Podcast and that was like
2018 I think 17. do you miss doing it
yeah but it was also like too short
because it was only 10 minutes that's a
lot of time yeah we had together a bunch
of them at the same time and I like
doing doozy way more I it the time flies
as we're you know like talking here
doing this [__] with you dude it's fun
uh I like that better
um but I did I did dig doing 10-minute
podcast for a few reasons one of them is
because it was Audio Only so it was a
little bit more theater of the mind and
I used to I used to like um I used to
you know I guess produce the show like I
would I would just geeking around in
GarageBand and I would bring in a bunch
of weird sound cues and stuff so for me
I man I love doing it it was real
creative it was fun and it was creative
and it was kind of therapeutic for me so
I loved nerding out and going like
recording the episode and thinking okay
I'm gonna put a a sound effect here and
do that and then later going going in
and especially at the end it got so
weird there were all these there was
this you know inside jokes like this NWO
uh theme song If you know you know
wrestling drops and a Charles Manson
thing remember that interviewer he's
like it made it into every episode was
like oh they say do you feel blame are
you mad
who's dead
that [__] meme of just are you mad do
you feel blame
this could be a [__] where it's like oh
[__] he's sort of making a little bit of
sense nope nope he's the devil Helter
Skelter horrible horrible horrible
horrible man the devil responsible for
all of it
killed a woman and a baby this is
terrible why am I putting this in my
podcast because there's nothing funnier
than are you mad do you feel blameless
which planet
[__] loses his [__] voice it's
[__] Charles Manson I was putting it
in every episode and then myself at the
end of the show
uh uh it was uh well first it was uh it
was Brian Chris you remember those guys
yeah yeah what are they up to and then
uh and then there was um Chad culchin
did it with me and her good buddy Tommy
blacher the funniest man in the world
and uh Tommy and I at least were always
like
did y'all ever think about starting it
back up was there ever a conversation
too uh yeah you know for a while uh like
a few years ago
uh yeah Brian and Chris were like maybe
you want to do this again and I was like
I don't
I don't know maybe and then uh I don't
know I think they're both living in
Costa Rica yeah what happened
yeah they uh they definitely hit they
hit some
snags everything's gonna be fine look be
honest uh yeah let's be be very
transparent get out ahead of uh any uh
issues you may have had or don't yeah I
don't know I don't have the answers
yeah I think a lot of that's hard to
yeah I mean I don't know I mean that
yeah that's all that's a good thing to
say is I don't know yeah yeah real yeah
but anyway that's kind of their own
Journeys yeah I mean I think they've
both been through it you know they've
both dealt with I mean different saw you
know they've been through a lot of that
yeah it's a lot it sure is a lot a whole
world of that is a lot whenever I start
to think about it I immediately stop
yeah yeah because I go like that's a lot
and uh yeah see I'm stopping right now
yeah
yeah same man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one